[Music]
it is october which means halloween is
right around the corner and to celebrate
we want to tell you a spooky story
a terrifying tale
a nightmarish
narrative but
this
is more than just a scary story it's the
story of something that actually
happened in the news
last week
and it happened here in this very
country
do you think you can hear such a
harrowing tale and survive
let's find out
[Music]
one foul eve in the month of
a crowd october
and they didn't seem sober
they came out to give us a fright
and did i mention they were blindingly
white and worse things in the night that
go bump
i saw signs that said blacks for trump
it was a trump rally
trump rally
there was something at the scary jump
rally
no finale
all the usual suspects showed up to
attend dude
you're on debbie and her q a non friends
even a lady calling for civil war it was
creepy and weird and horribly ghastly
and i just mean that speech by senator
grassley
[Music]
now here's something that'll leave you
stunned
they all legitimately think donald trump
won
a city trump rally
it was okay
no metallic the scary trump rally h2
fund was another trump rally
[Music]
you